let's go next to our caller from the 708
area code who is calling today from 7:08
I mean yes it is you know I saw on the
backlash you got over the last two
videos about the Medicare for all right
no we're never gonna get it and that
will not never but it's gonna be awhile
it was my point yeah but go ahead Isaiah
you know Sarah like um with me not being
really inspired to be even kind of vote
in 2016 to the both candidates was so
uninspired and as with meeting more so
with millions of people around like we
feel like it's realistic change with
important people Bernie because of the
things that he has promised they're
seeing so much realistic so if you know
with the damper up the fact that we
would never get it do you think that
were like turn told us off from getting
into the uh trying to vote for Bernie
no I my hope would be that it would
actually get people to do more than just
go out and vote for Bernie in the sense
that if you recognize that there's gonna
be way more to the fight for Medicare
for all than just electing Bernie for
example that it's going to be about and
somewhat someone emailed me and they
said you know David even if we take the
Senate and we get sixty votes if only
ten percent defect and say we don't want
Medicare for all it still wouldn't pass
and so that's why this is going to be a
much bigger fight I would hope that
people would say Oh getting Bernie in is
just step one then I've got to work at
the Senate I've got to work on
governorships I've got a lobby my member
of Congress you know there's a whole
bunch of other stuff that hopefully
people would be inspired to do the idea
is we're gonna need to do more than just
elect Bernie we can do it but we've got
to do it it's not just Bernie comes in
and we've got Medicare for all that's my
point the point as well but on the
Republican side of things I was burning
were bringing it back to Republicans her
burning saying that he wanted Medicare
for our bill that's changed like
everybody stands like this
and if you've got a have because it's
like I'm running for Medicare for all so
what is the Republican run for and 2020
to try to give owners like it
besides Donald Trump's last was he
really stay to spark his side of voters
besides the lab that he's already to are
you saying if you're Donald Trump what
do you run on in 2020 or if you are
another Republican what do you run on in
2020 Oh front runs on we know what he's
doing he's running on keep America great
he's running on the economy's fantastic
and were respected around the world and
we're doing the trade deal the USMC I
mean it's all lies but that's what he
runs on and if 62 million people fall
for it as long as they're in the right
states he wins re-election alright
appreciate the call thank you so much
Isaiah let's go next to our caller from
the 3:05 area code caller from 3:05
what's your name where you calling from
hi David my name is Michael I'm calling
from Coral Springs how are you good
what's going on so I was wondering David
I saw your video like the previous
previous caller in on Medicare for all
and it's unlikelihood to pass so I was
wondering where actually I was actually
commenting on something I thought you
might have framed as being or framed
wrong and possibly made you sound a
little bit too dismissive about Medicare
for all okay so that is that is I was
wondering is it not true that Medicare
for all does not seek to ban private
insurance but the main operation of
private insurance or private health care
insurance in this economy which is
duplicative care what will is what it
would be actually I know that came out
really wrong but no you're completely
right it's I it's been a widely
incorrectly stated claim that Medicare
for all by necessity will ban private
insurance I don't believe
that is the case but I'm going further
I'm saying that to the extent that it is
something some people want to do I don't
see legally how you do it but you're
completely correct and I've made this
point during debates it's not I don't I
don't believe most of the candidates are
looking to make private insurance
illegal that's correct I think that they
shouldn't try to I think they wouldn't
be able to and it's been misstated
before that they all want to but there
is also a mathematical reality of unless
you have all service providers accepting
Medicare for all that changes the
numbers and it was it was not an
argument like I was saying their goal is
to make in private insurance illegal I
was not saying that thank you so much
David that is exactly what I thought now
I appreciate you clearing that up
that being said last question if that's
okay with Elizabeth Warren now detailing
her plan on Medicare for all yes and I
understand the point that you were
making in that other video or one of the
points okay being that either way all of
this is the Medicare for all is going to
have trouble going through Congress I
wanted to ask as well now now that you
see Warren's plan for do you see
Bernie's plan for it we've seen it for a
long time now what do you see is more
viable and does that possibly make you
lean towards endorsing one of them in
the future I don't see either of the
plans as politically more or less viable
because I've already pointed out much to
the dismay of many in my audience that
in either case in either configuration
politically it will be a huge hill to
overcome I believe that Elizabeth
Warren's cost assessments were more
unrealistic than Bernie's I have a
problem with the way Bernie is assessing
predicted costs but I think Elizabeth
Warren is even more off the mark with it
but they are big picture they are pretty
similar plans in terms of what what it
would cost and what would be included
the difference is how Elizabeth Warren
would pay for it there are some
differences there but we've got a long
video
this which I encourage you to check out
alright thank you so much David I'm
sorry the call thank you you too great
to hear from you